[Avez-vous déjà triché à un examen ? ]
Nous avons dit à un groupe de sujets :
«Seuls d'autres étudiants vont voir vos réponses.»
Nous avons dit à un autre groupe :
«Les étudiants et les professeurs vont voir vos réponses.»
Transparence. Notification. Et, bien sûr, ça a marché,
dans le sens où le premier groupe de sujets
était beaucoup plus enclin à donner des informations que le second.
C'est logique, n'est-ce pas ?
Mais nous avons ensuite ajouté le détournement.
Nous avons répété l'expérience avec les deux mêmes groupes,
cette fois-ci, en ajoutant un délai
entre le moment où on a dit aux sujets
comment nous utiliserions leurs données
et le moment où on a commencé à leur poser des questions.
Combien de temps pensez-vous que nous ayonsdû ajouter
pour neutraliser l'effet inhibiteur
de savoir que les professeurs verraient vos réponses ?
Dix minutes ?
Cinq minutes ?
Une minute ?
Que diriez-vous de 15 secondes ?
Quinze secondes ont suffit pour que les deux groupes
divulguent la même quantité d'informations,
comme si le deuxième groupe ne se souciait plus
que les professeurs puissent lire ses réponses.
Je dois reconnaître que cette conférence, jusqu'ici,
peut sembler excessivement sombre,
mais ce n'est pas l'essentiel de mon message.
En fait, je veux vous montrer
qu'il existe des alternatives.
La façon dont on fait les choses aujourd'hui
n'est pas la seule manière de faire,
ni certainement la meilleure.
Si quelqu'un vous dit, « Les gens se fichent de préserver leur vie privée »,
demandez-vous si le jeu n'a pas été conçu
et truqué dans le but qu'ils ne puissent pas s'en soucier.
Réaliser que ces manipulations se produisent,
c'est déjà être à mi-chemin du processus
qui nous rend capables de nous protéger nous-mêmes.
Si quelqu'un vous dit que la protection de la vie privée est incompatible
avec les avantages du Big Data,
considérez qu'au cours des 20 dernières années,
les chercheurs ont créé des technologies
qui permettent à virtuellement toutes les transactions électroniques
de se dérouler d'une manière plus respectueuse de la vie privée.
On peut naviguer sur Internet de façon anonyme.
On peut envoyer des mails qui ne pourront être lus
que par le destinataire, pas même par la NSA.
Il peut même y avoir une exploitation des bases de données respectueuse de la vie privée.
En d'autres termes, nous pouvons avoir les avantages du Big Data
tout en protégeant la vie privée.
Bien sûr, ces technologies impliquent un changement
de la répartition des coûts et des revenus
entre les détenteurs de données et les personnes concernées,
ce qui explique peut-être pourquoi vous n'en entendez pas beaucoup parler.
Ce qui me ramène au Jardin d'Eden.
Il y a une seconde interprétation à propos de la vie privée
dans l'histoire du Jardin d'Eden
qui n'a rien à voir avec le fait
qu'Adam et Eve se sentent nus
et honteux.
Vous pouvez trouver les échos de cette interprétation
dans "Le Paradis perdu" de John Milton.
Dans le jardin, Adam et Eve sont contentés sur le plan matériel.
Ils sont heureux. Ils sont satisfaits.
Cependant, ils n'ont ni la connaissance,
ni la conscience d'eux-mêmes.
Au moment où ils mangent le bien nommé
fruit de la connaissance,
c'est là qu'ils se découvrent eux-mêmes.
Ils prennent conscience. Ils parviennent à l'autonomie.
Cependant, le prix à payer, c'est de quitter le jardin.
La vie privée, d'une certaine manière, c'est à la fois le moyen
et le prix à payer pour la liberté.
Encore une fois, les spécialistes du marketing nous disent
que le Big Data et les réseaux sociaux
ne sont pas seulement pour eux un paradis du profit,
mais aussi un Jardin d'Eden pour nous autres.
Nous bénéficions de contenus gratuits.
Nous avons la chance de jouer à Angry Birds. Nous avons des applications ciblées.
Mais en fait, dans quelques années, ces organisations
sauront tant de choses sur nous,
qu'ils seront en mesure de déduire nos désirs
avant que nous les ayons formés, et peut-être
d'acheter des produits en notre nom
avant qu'on ne réalise qu'on en a besoin.
Il y a un auteur anglais
qui a anticipé ce genre de futur
dans lequel nous abandonnerions
notre autonomie et notre liberté pour du confort.
Plus encore que George Orwell,
cet auteur est, bien sûr, Aldous Huxley.
Dans « Le Meilleur des Mondes », il imagine une société
dans laquelle les technologies que nous avons créées
à l'origine pour la liberté
finissent par nous contraindre.
Toutefois, dans ce livre, il nous offre aussi une porte de sortie
de cette société, semblable au chemin
qu'Adam et Ève ont eu à suivre pour quitter le jardin.
Selon les termes du Sauvage,
retrouver l'autonomie et la liberté est possible,
bien que le prix à payer soit élevé.
Je crois fermement que l'un des combats décisifs
de notre époque sera le combat
pour le contrôle des informations personnelles,
le combat pour savoir si les Big Data peuvent devenir un vecteur
de liberté,
plutôt qu'un moyen de nous manipuler à notre insu.
À l'heure actuelle, bon nombre d'entre nous
ne savent même pas que le combat a commencé,
mais c'est le cas, que ça vous plaise ou non.
Et au risque de jouer les serpents,
je vous dirais que les outils pour ce combat
sont là, la conscience de ce qui est en train de se passer,
et dans vos mains,
à quelques clics seulement.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)